installing 2% what the [ __ ] and we have
to do fungus and [ __ ] get the party
started
I'm saying
you
you came on a good night [ __ ]
uncle Joey here Lisa out here nerd man
Jerry is on his way we're gonna play
mafia 3 I'm gonna smoke some dope and
we'll eat some metal before the church
Wednesday the 26 the beautiful thing is
you are here [ __ ] you've arrived
we're here tonight Wayne how much
tonight we got two different types of
weed we got some [ __ ] stars of death
which leaves about the nail right now
fresh out the box you can hear my sound
from blocks and blocks bad [ __ ] will
go in deep it's what the 3% we'll be in
for a [ __ ] while you just count these
[ __ ] off right here
there you go Lee there's three there's
five we're going deep right off that
[ __ ] bunny Street weed ten right off
the bat a eagle nine
oh [ __ ] six one fell on the floor we
eatin [ __ ] 1,200 off the back one two
weight [ __ ] around no more I've been
telling you guys for years now three
oh [ __ ] a little hint water for you
[ __ ] you know how we do it hey
open this up y'all go Joey
my wrist is on four
[Music]
nice little water with a splash of fruit
oh [ __ ] oh you made me lose count for
Willie's seven [ __ ] hey going you'll
always be buddy that's it
[ __ ] tap the back and we'll eat the
other half a bag with mafia three
[ __ ] downloads here how you guys
doing you thought I forgot about you
[ __ ] I'm listening to one of my
favorite albums of all [ __ ] time this
album is sensational 7 [ __ ] stars 14
hundred milligrams right off the bat for
that you understand me
we ain't got time to [ __ ] around if
you're under 18 hang up now I ain't got
time to [ __ ] babysit I don't know
what's going on with the Chicago game
all I know is we're smoking reefer we're
eating edibles we'll listen to music
with a download mafia 3 and see what
it's all about
we're gonna [ __ ] kill me 18 times but
that's for right now I'm wisdom when the
greatest albums I've ever had the
pleasure listening to when God put the
ears on my big fat [ __ ] head he goes
is the most important thing you gonna
hear in your [ __ ] life
the police synchronicity you will never
hear now so [ __ ] I have only come
here seeking knowledge things they would
not teach me of in college are you
[ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me that sting now you gotta
understand I can't stand [ __ ] stink
he's an egotistical [ __ ] him and
Roger Waters I hate them [ __ ] both
cuz they both broke up a band you're
gonna sit there and say well Mick
Jagger's nigo yeah but he kept the band
together you understand regardless of
how I feel and personal emotions this is
still in my top ten wrapped around your
finger you can't write this [ __ ] I'll be
wrapped around your finger just
tremendous brings back a lot of memories
some were [ __ ] 83 G's Oh boom what it
was diesel juice and my [ __ ] bedroom
with the [ __ ] police you understand
me i feelingly fourteen hundred years
till five eight two forty two hours ago
he's still [ __ ] diddling around I'm
you got three stars left yeah you better
get to eat look at the camera
it's time for did you say bong it I'm
just I just want to make sure what door
you opening tonight
don't be looking at the screen and I'm
doing it flake on second it's a
beautiful 90s Southern California
I'm happy you're joining us for the
church we're just downloading the Mafia
three grain Jerry's on his way over is I
teach me how to play I never played a
game listen even if prisoner they play
no [ __ ] games I ain't got the [ __ ]
aptitude for that [ __ ] I like to smoke
reefer and read books and watch movies
and [ __ ] last time I play the game was
monopoly I like it every time I got
Boardwalk Empire I [ __ ] quit I didn't
buy a hotel but who gives a [ __ ] about
my games history is [ __ ] when I hear
four that we came to get down we came to
get down so he left off your feet and
jump around jump around jump jump jump
and get down [ __ ] Wednesday
night [ __ ] you
uncle Joey we show it tonight and I was
busy all day
now the Bell you understand me 8:2
[ __ ] had a drive to Santa Monica I was
on Olympic Boulevard for Joey what's
with the [ __ ] itinerary we don't give
a Frenchman's [ __ ] oh yeah look at
that smoke your thing that shows up with
smoke like that's a magician or Satan
you bad [ __ ] I'm happy you're
here Lee is ready for a bum knee you
know Lee's ready is in training you be
wrapped around my finger
are you [ __ ] nuts this is good as a
guest ladies and gentlemen up with
Joey's offering your synchronously
[ __ ] tremendous and the police got
some fat [ __ ] out don't get confused
just cuz I don't like stink don't mean
that you know I'm in I'm in ego my
brother the bond of life compels you
[Music]
toughest [ __ ] shoe-leather tougher
than [ __ ] shoe literally back up and
[ __ ] Italian shoe leather look at me
he's growing [ __ ] head on his neck as
long as tougher than death [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with here huh
you think I show up with some [ __ ]
Jim Jim Magoo [ __ ] no I show up with
[ __ ] savages I gotta turn this out
give me a minute here we go [ __ ]
I'm back
never fear uncle Joey's here oh [ __ ]
will synchronicity some [ __ ] bomb the
dose
kick that door open we [ __ ] it's time if
the asset is we got nothing mom
synchronicity
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey rockin rockin cool synchronicity and
you [ __ ] nuts
Jerry LaRocca back when was the last
time you showed up with a pink floyd
shirt don't meet dick it's your [ __ ]
night you call it [ __ ] blackjack
bonnets for chlamydia it's that type of
[ __ ] language well we asked 21-foot a
21% complete
un-fuckin'-believable how was it take
the [ __ ] we are like family to a
fungus on Thanksgiving I got a recipe
for stopping
start the podcast is an absolute podcast
we'll play mafia [ __ ] three give you a
chance to go to your dealers house get
some heroin
open that door leave the door get the
central be here all the usual suspects
you don't give us to them straight no I
move to work so there I got an office in
the back take a look like a white person
I got many Gentiles for babies I used to
little crusty from two [ __ ] [ __ ]
now the first people normal people what
you his sabotage in the morning you're
gonna have a good [ __ ] man and then
have a spiritual awakening I'm saying as
they say you ready for another star Lee
all right we're 49
what 1400 people pleasing to leave here
and go to a diner and say [ __ ] draw
draw I got 10 stars in me how to eat
dinner like uncle Joey told me to
oh honey one yeah that's my all-time
great cowboy dude all-time [ __ ]
Hollywood he was the first bad
[ __ ] my first bag oh my god
Hollywood Henderson for the Dallas
Cowboys got fired he won the Super Bowl
single handily as the Broncos he had to
separate the boys and he said he was
going to do it if he called his own all
this whole [ __ ] game you know what I
found out too-tall Jones what's happened
you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey ain't
done yet
Lee you ready you're up [ __ ]
hearing noises Charlie tell these people
is when the greatest now it was a wall
oh my god and you know I can't stand
sting sting sting needed the other guys
once he got low once he left the police
thought that you know he shows up
because it's so now he's crazy growing
his beard Lee Fedele [ __ ] what's the
story P but I forget about hey I'm just
getting my head together trying to
[ __ ] activate the throat to get ready
to give you a good [ __ ] podcast that's
nothing wrong with that
and Roger Waters the other guy can't
even look at them so we should all he
did that [ __ ] festival and he
actually did dogs all my friends from
Jersey taped it put on Facebook I call
them right away the dog I can't believe
you sat down through that I wouldn't sit
through dog it [ __ ] give your Moines
playing the guitar
if Gomory playing the guitar uncle Joey
don't sit through dogs I'm sorry I gotta
go for a walk as a matter of fact I
gotta [ __ ] leave that's how strong I
am
I don't want to see it I would never
want to see the guitar I'm dogs played
by anybody else except French what are
you gonna do with drop and Phil Collins
type [ __ ] yeah anyway we're gonna
start we're at 34 percent downloaded on
the [ __ ] mafia 3 we're gonna start
the podcast run with that and then we'll
come back to mafia 3 later on so all you
[ __ ] game is you're gonna watch uncle
Joey game for the first [ __ ] time I
know it'll be the East Coast you're done
but your [ __ ] in England you're
up all night
Australia you're up all night Frankie
bark and the boys and that's it we'll be
back in ten minutes at the podcast a
black [ __ ] love you